what's up internets this is John Delaney
with Ramsey Network today we were
talking about fear and failure and
anxiety I'm so stressed that I'm tanking
my life okay I'm gonna be answering an
email that somebody sent in to ask John
at Remzi solutions calm so here we go hi
John what's up hope you're doing good I
am good good very good hope your day is
going well
big time it is firstly I want to let you
know that I really enjoy your YouTube
videos and your insights when you
co-host the Dave Ramsey show thank you
let's be honest I'm carrying that show
we all know that but whatever my name is
Michael I'm finishing my first year as a
staff accountant in a big four
accounting firm I still need to pass all
four sections of the CPA exam I stopped
studying in December as I had multiple
medical conditions I needed to take care
of and working from home during kovat
has been challenging enough let alone
finding time to study as well my wife
and I had our second child five weeks
ago dude you got a lead with that one
right that's a big deal congratulations
I know I have a lot on my plate but I
realized that there will never be a
perfect time to study and it only gets
harder to tackle these exams as I
advance in my career yes I failed two of
the four tests thus far and truthfully I
failed pretty miserably and I knew going
into the exam I was not prepared I've
been reflecting on that experience and I
realized it was not just the material
that was a big challenge but the mental
battle of continuing to persevere make
mistakes and stay patient when I'm not
getting something
but getting to study again I'm gonna
make sure I'm better prepared with a
healthy mindset thank you for your
contributions to helping so many people
I hope like 30 to 36 48 people max but
thank you Michael I appreciate your
vulnerability your email and so let's
dig in okay so first I want to look at
the facts here ok the last let's say six
months you've had major medical
conditions
your wife and you had a second kid who's
now five weeks old
that means you've also had a pregnant
wife in your home under lockdown under
quarantine
probably cut off from her community
probably worried about kovat
and pregnancy and the baby and all that
number three you work for a big four
accounting firm as an associate that
means you mow the lawn out front in
addition to doing the accounting work
and making coffee and making sure
everybody's good that's a hard job and
so congratulations on landing that job
but it's tough you also have another kid
that you have to parent who's now has a
baby brother or sister that just got
brought into the house that's a lot
Michael nothing in your life should be
smooth right now every anxiety alarm you
have should be going off right now
we're in the middle of a pandemic you're
a new dad for the second time you've got
a crazy job that's super busy you've got
a wife who has been pregnant and there's
now a new mom and you've had major
medical issues that's what anxiety is
for to let you know man things are not
good
and then you pile on top of that one of
the hardest licensure exams there is
which is a CPA exam and for those of you
who don't know CPA exam is four separate
exams that you got to pass in succession
to be able to be licensed and if Michael
here doesn't pass Michael gets fired
from his job
he's probably got a mortgage he's got
two little kids he's got his own medical
issues that's a lot of pressure and you
say here that you tanked the exam you
didn't study very hard in fact you
self-sabotage you knew going in you
weren't gonna pass this exam and you
crashed it so congratulations Michael
you attempted to crash the plane and you
succeeded so we're already on to step
two right not really
but here's the deal anxiety and fear
stress us out they run our cortisol and
adrenaline if you've been doing it for
two weeks or four weeks or four months
or six months and then you get a real
stressful moment you got nothing left in
the tank
you just get exhausted and it burns you
out so Michael here's what I'm
recommending you do okay we're gonna go
through four steps all right so number
one facts are your friends I want you to
write down the facts of this situation
you got hired by a big four firm
they don't just hand those jobs out okay
that means you are a stud when it comes
to academic work you've been really
successful in the classroom
that means you passed a rigorous
rigorous interview process and you must
be good you must be good at what you're
doing and you must have shown in the
past you've demonstrated you being good
before that means you can be successful
that means that a big floor firm said
that guy Michael is gonna make us money
they would not have hired you on a whim
they would not have hired you if they
thought he might be successful they
don't have time for that they put a lot
of money into the recruitment they put a
lot of money into the wooing and the
signing of you Michael you have proven
that you can be successful as an
accountant everything up till now has
led to this moment you can do it I want
you to lean on that fact fact number two
your life has been a hurricane blizzard
diarrhea storm for the past two months
four months six months it should not be
smooth it should not be easy it's okay
that it's nuts it's okay that it's crazy
so I want you to take a spiral out and I
want you to write down your feelings the
things that you have experienced over
the last four or five six months and it
may take a minute or it may just all
come flooding out on you but I want you
to write down what you felt like when
your wife told you she was pregnant I
want you to write down your fears about
parenting two kids and how are you gonna
balance that I want you to write down
your fears about your new job and your
successes and how frustrating some
things are and I want you to be honest
about the questions you're asking
yourself is this really what you want to
do for the rest of your life because
anyone who joins a big four firm always
ask themself a few months in is this
what I signed up for
be honest and vulnerable with yourself
and I want you to write about your fears
of your medical conditions I want you to
write about your frustrations with
having to work from home and I want you
to write about your fears about it's
just ever going to end and as an
accountant you know the financial
nuclear winter we are about to enter
because of the kovat shutdown
you know you're looking at the numbers
every day in your job you're hearing
your colleagues talk around the water
coolers I want you to write about your
financial fears want you to be honest
with yourself you got to get them out of
your head and onto the paper and I want
you to acknowledge the reality that they
are fact number three you got a bruised
ego because you failed and if you're
working where you're working
you've probably not failed a lot in your
life now that's a wild generalized guess
maybe you've been a string of failures
through your whole life and you stumbled
into the back door of a big four
accounting firm but probably not you
were probably a stud in elementary
school you probably did pretty good
your junior high you're a rock star in
high school
you killed it in college and now you've
landed this dope awesome job and then
you failed your tests and you knew you
could do better but your egos bruised
man and it sucks
own it sucks I'm disappointed myself
that I failed and then I want you to
stand up I want you to call somebody
that you care about that you can be
vulnerable with and say dude I'm
embarrassed that I didn't work hard or I
failed because I had so many other more
important things going on like my health
and my wife's health and my new baby
that I didn't put the time in and that's
oh okay
and then fact number four you will pass
your exams you will be successful if you
choose to be so when the time is right
and it might not be right now you say
you're about to start studying again so
good for you
if you're ready to rock and roll and
ready to party then go get it done I
want you to go be brave being brave
means you will make a schedule every day
with your wife and you will stick to it
being brave means you will study
rigorously and you will sleep and
exercise even if it's taking a walk
around the block and you will hug your
new kid you will hug your other kid
you'll stay connected to them you will
take care of your relationships
and you will study like you've never
studied before you'll pay the money and
get a course if you need to you will
bracket off time away from your wife and
your kids and you will crush this exam
if you choose to you will own it and
then you will pass your exams and then
it's time for regulators to mount up mic
will be rocking on to the break of dawn
this is dr. John Delaney with Ramsey
Network thanks for joining us subscribe
all of the internet things follows ATS
hit the little red subscribe button man
what else do you can just click on it
man it's for me it's for my kids it's
for my granddad I'm making that up Rocco
and be safe be nice